For years and years, we've had labour, uh,
administrations, this area,
labour politicians, and we feel as though we've been let down,
let down on traditions,
uh, customs,
you know, religion, even.
The feel is all to be marginalized.
And obviously the debate after Brexit was a classic debate of people,
politicians really sent the people in this area really.
Yeah, yeah.
You don't, you know.
Condescending approach.
So what is changed in 4 years when you lost all them seats?
What is gonna convince the working class and the works around here
that you've changed and you're gonna invest in this area?
Look, I'm really pleased to have this quick, um,
question, because we've lost four elections in a row.
We lost in 2019, um,
really badly.
And I took over after that loss and I looked at those results
and I came to the same conclusion as you did.
It wasn't the voters that have got it wrong,
it was the Labour Party that got it wrong.
And therefore we shouldn't.
I didn't think we should go back to the voters and say,
didn't you hear us last time?
Um, and shout a bit louder.
I said, we're gonna change the Labour Party.
We're gonna turn it inside out. Backwards.
Because, um,
the Labour Party was set up to support working people,
to fight for working people.
That was the central purpose of the Labour Party.
And we drifted too far from that
and that's why we got the result We got in 2019,
and so I've changed the Labour Party
to put it back in the service of working people.
So we have changed the Labour Party.
So what we're putting before the country this year
in that general election is not the same Labour Party put in 2019.
I didn't feel, we didn't feel,
as a team, that we had the right to go back to the country
and effectively say to voters like,
you know, you got it wrong.
We got it wrong. And your criticism of what we got wrong is bang on.